Credit recovery programs are on the rise.
These programs let high-school students
who have fallen behind make up credits
needed to graduate, without retaking the
original course. As they've spread, so
have scandals where schools use lax
credit recovery programs to boost grad
rates. So what policies do school
districts have to ensure credit recovery
matches their academic standards? We
surveyed 200 to find out. Turns out
district policies prioritize flexibility
with minimal quality control. Most
programs are available online, all year,
to all students. Plus, most let students
pretest out of lessons with no minimum
seat time and no school-administered
exams. Schools face obvious pressure to
raise grad rates, which is why school
districts need policies that answer the
question, "How will you ensure rigor in
your credit recovery programs?" When
districts have no good answer, students
suffer. To truly help struggling
students, districts need to craft
policies that prioritize rigor, or risk
being in the headline for the next
credit recovery scandal.
Should credit recovery courses be just as rigorous as standard courses? Let us know in our poll.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.